[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
بعد زيارته لبيكين ماكرون يدعو اوروبا
لرفض التبعيه لواشنطن ودولارها وازماتها
تداعيات فضيحه تسريبات البنتاجون مستمره
كوريا الجنوبيه تريد توضيحات على التنصت
عليها
الصين تعلنوا عن محاكاه عسكريه لاستعاده
تايوان والاخيره تتعهد بالرد المناسب
الى المشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من العلاقات
بين واشنطن وباريس ففي اعقاب زياره الرئيس
ايمانويل ماكرون الى العاصمه الصينيه بكين
يبدو ان التوترات عرفت طريقها وبشكل عالمي
بين باريس وبين اداره بايدن بحسب صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه فان زيارتها
رغم التوتر بين واشنطن تؤكد مره اخرى ان
الحلفاء في اوروبا لا ينظرون الى الامور
من الزاويه نفسها بالضروره ففي احدث تصريح
يظهر عن هذه الخلافات ويظهر هذه الخلافات
ايضا شدد ماكرون على ضروره ان تقلل اوروبا
من اعتمادها على الولايات المتحده ان
تتجنب ايضا الانجرار الى مواجهه بين
بكينوا واشنطن بشان تايوان ماكرون قال ان
الخطر الكبير الذي قد تواجهه اوروبا هو
الوقوع في ازمات ليست من ازماتها مؤكدا
انه ليس من مصلحه اوروبا العمل على تسريع
ازمه تايوان وبناء موقفها بالتبعيه
للولايات المتحده او بتلميحات من الصين
معتبرا انه في حال اشتدت التوترات بين
هاتين القوتين
فليكون لاوروبا الوقت ولا الموارد لتمويل
استقلالها الاستراتيجي ماكرون اضاف ان على
اوروبا تقليل اعتمادها على الدولار
الامريكي خارج الحدود الاقليميه
الى تداعيات ازمتي وثائق البينتاجون
المسربه مسؤولون في كوريا الجنوبيه قالوا
ان سيول على علم بالتقارير الاعلاميه
المتعلقه بهذا التسريب تسريب الوثائق
المكتب الرئاسي في سيول اعلن انه سيجرم
مناقشات ضروريه مع المخابرات الامريكيه
بشان هذه التسريبات وكانت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز قد ذكرت ان الوثائق المسربه تحتوي
على تفاصيل حول مناقشات خاصه بين كبار
المسؤولين في كوريا الجنوبيه حول الضغط
الامريكي على بلادهم للمساعده في امداد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
ميدانيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
طائره من طراز خويسو 34 استهدفت جسرا في
تشيرني هيف الاوكرانيه وذلك لمنع قوات
اوكرانيه تابعه للمخابرات من التقدم
باتجاه الاراضي الروسيه
ومنطقه بريانسكي الحدوديه بالتحديد
اشار وزير الخارجيه الاستوني اورما الى ان
سلطات بلاده قد تشتري مقاتلات امريكيه من
طراز اف 16 وبعد ذلك تسلمها الى اوكرانيا
كان البيت الابيض قد نفى الشهر الماضي
وجود خطط لدى واشنطن لتدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين على مقاتلات اف 16 في الوقت
الراهن كما اعتبر الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن حينها ان تزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات
امريكيه ليس اولويه لدى ادارته
وفي تداعيات العقوبات الغربيه على موسكو
كانت صناعه الادويه في روسيا طبعا من ضمن
ابرز القطاعات المتضرره ما ادى الى ارتفاع
اسعار بعض الادويه وايضا نقص البعض الاخر
في الاسواق كاتي طعم معها التفاصيل
في معمل الادويه الروسيه هذا هو الذي ي
نتج من 20 عاما نطاقا واسعا من الادويه
على راسها الانسولين تحدي ات دوده الان
منها زياده الانتاج في ظل تقارير لجنه
وزاره الصحه
الروسيه عن وجود قائمه بما يقرب من 100
دواء صنف في خانه الادويه النا
الصيدليات والمستشفيات
على خلفيه الاحداث الاخيره ازداد الطلب
على الادويه في روسيا واختفت بعض الادويه
من الصيدليات ضررنا لزياده الانتاج من اجل
تامين السوق الروسيه بالادويه الهامه
لحياه الانسان لان الانسولين هو ماده هامه
لا يستطيع الانسان العيش من دونها
لم تكد هذه الشركه لتتعافى من تداعيات
كورونا وانقطاع الواردات من المواد الخام
حينها حتى بدات تواجه تداعيات العقوبات
التي فرضت على روسيا لتبدا البحث عن بدائل
للموردين للمواد والمعدات الطبيه
بعد فرض العقوبات ولكن خلال فتره قصيره
استطعنا تغيير المصدرين ووجدنا شركاء جددا
من الدول الصديقه والذين يستطيعون تصدير
كل ما يلزمنا من معدات ومواد اوليه
استقلال روسيا عن الادويه المستورده
وزياده انتاج الادويه المحليه هدفان
وضعهما الرئيس الروسي امام الصناعه
الدوائيه في البلاد مع التاكيد على ضروره
زياده انتاج مواد الخام المحليه لتحقيقها
الادويه ذات المجموعه الواسعه التطبيق لم
تختفي من السوق ولم ترتفع اسعارها لكن
الادويه الغاليه تمني والتي
تامر الحياه في ظل
الامر نعم اختفت
وتراجعي نسبه الواردات من الادويه الى
روسيا الى نحو تسعه بالمئه تبقى التساؤلات
لدى المواطن الروسي حول مدى امكانيه شركات
الادويه المحليه تعويض هذا النقص كاتيا
العربيه موسكو
عن تاجيل الاجتماع وزراء خارجيه روسيا
ايران تركيا وايضا سوريا الى اوائل شهر
مايو المقبل وقال يفمون ان الاجتماع الذي
كان من المقرر عقده يوم غد الاثنين تم
تاجيله مشيرا الى ان الاتصالات والمشاورات
مستمره بين الاطراف المعنيه للوصول الى
نتائج ايجابيه في هذا الاطار
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
وفدان سعودي وعمان يصلان صنعاء لبحث جهود
احلال السلام
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ونكمل من
التصعيد في مضيق تايوان حيث تتصاعد
التوترات وبشكل تدريجي ما ينذر بامكانيه
حدوث مواجهه في اي وقت طبعا فالصين ماضيه
في مناورات عسكريه حول جزيره تايوان ردلا
على زياره رئيسه تايوان للولايات المتحده
ولقائها بالمسؤولين الامريكيين فاين
بالتحديد هذه التدريبات الصينيه وما هو
حجم هذه التدريبات بحسب مصدر امنيه
تايواني فان التدريبات الصينيه تقع حول
قناه باشا التي تفصل تايوان عن الفلبين
التدريبات الصينيه تضمنت محاكاه لضربات
دقيقه على اهداف رئيسيه في تايوان ولتطويق
الجزيره
وبالكامل وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه تقول
انها رصدت مقاتلات صينيه من بينها مقاتلات
سو 30 وقذفات h6 الى جانب احدى عشره سفينه
حربيه اخرى في محيط الجزيره من جانبها
قالت رويترز نقلا عن مصادر مطلعه ان
المواجهات باتت وشيكا حيث تت عشره سفن
صينيه ومثلها تايوانيه على خط المواجهه
بالقرب من الخط الاوسط للجزيره تايبي اكدت
انها لن تسهم في التصعيد لكنها توعدت
بالرد وبالشكل الملائم على تدريبات بكين
واشنطن حليفه تايوان من جانبها قالت انها
تراقب المناورات الصينيه عن كثب مؤكده
انها تمتلك ما يكفي من موارد وقدرات لضمان
السلامه والاستقرار بالمنطقه
سفر وليست تساي الى بلدان مختلفه له تاثير
في زياده وعي الجميع بالتايوان على نطاق
دولي بالطبع لا يمكن تجنب بعض التخويف
اللفظي والعسكري من الصين التهديد الصيني
مستمر منذ فتره طويله ومن المستحيل ان
يختفي
الحديث المستمر عن الوحده مع الصين غير
ضروري على الاطلاق الصين تتحدث عن الوحده
وتهدد باعمال عسكريه اذا تمكنا من عيش
حياتنا بالطريقه الحاليه وجعل التايوان
تثبت وجودها عالميا فستكون الامور بخير
اعتقد ان هذا هو المهم الان
الى اليمن الان حيث نقلت وكاله الرويترز
عن اعلام يمني ان وفدا سعوديا واخر من
سلطنه عمان وصل الى العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء
لبحث لجهود احلال السلام بحسب رويترز فان
اللقاءات ستشمل المبعوثه الاممي وقضت
الحوثيين لبحث تمديد الهدنه والعمل على
اجراءات لبناء الثقه واختبار التوصل الى
حل سياسي شامل في اليمن
في تداعيات الهجوم على مطار السليمانيه
شماليه العراق والذي نسب الى تركيا وبينما
تضاربت الانباء حول محاوله اغتيال فاشله
طالت قائد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه قصد
مظلوم عبدي في المطار خرج عبدي نفسه لاحقا
لمهاجمه الرئيس التركي اتهمه بخلط الاوراق
والبحث عن برائع تخدم مصالحه في مرحله
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه المقبله
بحسب تصريحاته
وجود غرف عمليات مشتركه باشراف التحالف
الدولي مع قوات محاربه الارهاب في العراق
وكردستان العراق لمحاربه داعش وهو ما لا
يقبل به اردوغان على حد تعبيره سبق لرئيس
حزب الاتحاد الوطني الكردستاني بافل
طالباني ان قام بزياره عبدي في مقر اقامته
في شمال شرقي سوريا في اواخر العام الماضي
وهو ما اثار غضب تركيا التي تعارض تعاون
الحزب المستمر منذ سنوات مع قصد تشير
التقارير الى ان انقره اراده اصاله رساله
الى قاده حزب الاتحاد الوطني في معقله
بمدينه السليمانيه بسبب علاقاته مع قوات
قصد المدعومه ايضا من واشنطن فعبدي لم يكن
بمفرده عند استهداف المطار بل كان برفقه
مسؤولنا امريكيين من التحالف الدولي الذي
تقوده واشنطن
اردوغان وتركيا لم يصل الى هدفهما في هذه
العمليه لانه كما رايناه هناك تكاتف من
قبل الاصدقاء وادانه واسعه لها خاصه من
قبل الحلفاء في اقليم كردستان والعراق
والحلفاء في محاربه داعش هذه ليست المره
الاولى التي يتم استهدافنا ولن تكون
الاخيره لذلك نؤكد لشعبنا ولحلفائنا ان
جهودنا لحمايه مكتسبات ثوره شمال شرق
سوريا ستصبح اقوى وان هذه الهجمات لن
تفشلها
في مكه المكرمه تواصل القطاعات الصحيه
تقديمه خدماتها على مدار الساعه لخدمه
المعتمرين والزوار والمصلين في المسجد
الحرام مراسل العربيه افاد بان الخطه
الصحيه لضيوف الرحمن تعمل وفق منظومه
متكامله للتقديم افضل الخدمات الصحيه
وتعمل الخطه على اسس علميه وتجارب السابقه
بما في ذلك تجهيز كافه المستشفيات
والمراكز الصحيه بمكه المكرمه لاستقبال
جميع الحالات
المزيد ده ينضم الينا من الحرم المكي
مراسل العربيه اسامه القاسم اهلا بك اسامه
انقل لنا المشهد من عندك
اهلا وسهلا ميسون تحيه طيبه لكل جميع
المشاهدين العربيه نعما نقول لكم الصوت
والصور اليوم من الحرم المكي الشريف
وبالتحديد من الدور المطاف العلوي الثالث
وهو سطح المطاف طبعا اتحدث اليوم عن
الخدمات الصحيه المقدمه للزوار والمعتمرين
في مكه المكرمه تم تجهيز عشره مستشفيات في
جميع انحاء منطقه مكه المكرمه وايضا 82
مركزا صحيا بالاضافه الى عدد من المراكز
الصحيه المتوزعه جنبات المسجد الحرم اما
في المسجد الحرام فهناك مستشفى الحرم
للطوارئ ومستشفى اجياد وثلاث نقاط اسعافيه
داخل ساحات المسجد الحرامي اضافه الى
الخدمات المقدمه من الهلال الاحمر سواء
النقاط الاسعافيه او حتى متطوعي الدفاع
المدني اذا ميسون كيف تكون الحاله
الموجوده في الحرم المكي بدايه تباشرها
جهات المسؤوله ومنها الهلال الاحمر
يباشرون الحاله في حال اذا كانت هذه
الحاله عباره عن جرح بسيط او اعياء لمرضى
السكر والضغط فيتم مباشرتها وحلها بذات
الوقت اما اذا كانت الحاله تستدعي الذهاب
الى
المختصه الى لحظتنا هذه لم تسجل اي حالات
كبيره انما مجرد حالات اعياء بسيطه سواء
على مستوى المرضى بالامراض المزمنه او حتى
كبار السن ايضا مصدر مسؤول من الهلال
الاحمر ان هناك اكثر من عشره الاف حاله
بسيطه تم معالجتها من بدايه شهر رمضان
المبارك الى منتصف شهر رمضان المبارك منال
الحرم المكي مراسل العربيه اسامه القاسم
شكرا جزيلا لك
في الاردن وطيله شهر رمضان الفضيل يسارع
المتطوعون في تلبيه دعوات الخير لتقديم
المساعدات للعوائل المتعففه والمحتاجين
عبر المشاركه في توفير وجبات الافطار في
موائد الرحمن دعونا نتابع
[موسيقى]
عابروا السبيل والمحتاج والاف الاسر
العفيفه يتجمعون هنا في المكان نفسه
والوقت ذاته من كل عام مشهد مات تقليدا
اصيلا في رمضان فيه موائد الرحمن تستقبل
الصائمين وتقدم لهم وجبات الافطار بحب لا
يقابل الا بالكثير من الحب ودعوه من القلب
نقوم على خدمه حوالي 3500 صائم يوميا بقوم
على خدمتهم حوالي 80 متطوع بالاضافه الى
الى موظفي ليتكيه وهاي حاله تفاعليه جميله
والمتطوعين بصراحه في عنا ضغط كبير يعني
من المتطوعين اللي هو صار بتطوع موائد
الرحمن عليه تقليد يعني من تقاليد رمضان
بالنسبه لهم زي الفانوس سنوات طويله مرت
وتكيه ام علي تعمل على خدمه الصائمين عمل
وجد به المتطوعون اسمى اهدافهم حتى استمر
الكثير منهم بتحضير الطعام وتقديمه في
تكيه ام علي لاكثر من عشر سنوات كل اشي
بتقدمه وحتى بتشوف الناس بتكون مبسوطه
وانت لما تقدمي لهم اشي بتكون يعني في
ايجابي منك ومنهم اكيد شعور بالفرح
انه الاقل حظا والناس المحتاجين اكيد شعور
بالعطاء والعطاء ما له حدود اغتنام وشهري
رمضان في عمل الخير له وجه اخر هنا فتحت
عنوان سبيل صويلح يحضر مجموعه من الشباب
وجبات الافطار للعوائل العفيفه كما يقومون
بالبحث عن اي محتاج تعفف عن السؤال نقوم
بتوزيع ما لا يقل عن 100 صدر يوميا ويصل
العدد في بعض الايام الى 130 140 صدر
يوميا بفضل الله تعالى
نستهدف من يعني عملنا بفضل الله تعالى
الاخوه الذين يستحقون عملنا في هذا الشهر
المبارك وما وضع اقتصادي صعب وسوء احوال
الكثير من المواطنين تقدم هذه المبادرات
الرمضانيه جل ما يحتاجه كثيرون في شهر شرع
ابوابه لاعمال الخير سها جميل العربيه
عمان
[موسيقى]
نصحت شرطه مدينه هامبرج الالمانيه
المواطنين باغلاق نوافذهم وذلك بعد اندلاع
حريق هائل اجتاح العديد من المستودعات هذا
الحريق ايضا ادى الى انتشار دخان اسود
مليء بالمواد الكيميائيه في وسط المدينه
هذا الدخان دخان الحريق انتشر باتجاه وسط
المدينه طبعا ما ادى الى توقف حركه
القطارات بين همبرج وبرلين وايضا مدن اخرى
دعونا نتابع
وبهذه الصور مشاهدينا نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه نشره الخامسه طبعا لمتابعه ملفات
العربيه والمزيد من الاخبار تابع موقعنا
العربيه ايضا رجاء مسح الكود الظاهر على
الشاشه شكرا للمتابعه مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات